what is happening there citizens of
the reject Nation we are here today
to watch the final trailer for Avatar
the way of water John how goes it I feel
strong how do you feel is that a reference
isn't that what she says about the new home tree
home tree yeah you know the big old tree
that they plug their tail feathers into
when does anger Cora do any of that okay guys all
right let's watch this leave a like before you do
holy crap this is going to be us
throughout the whole movie damn
you come to us
nope I just want to keep my family safe
nice there you go as our brothers and sisters
wow
sport if you want to live here
this looks great the water
oh my God just breathe breathe
hey that's handshock yeah
stunning
cast that's all they see
I see
I see you I see you
why are you like you I'm supposed
to fight this music is so swelling
wow
that was a is that a Stephen langatar I think so
my goodness wowie my goodness
oh yes Avatar the way of water tickets on sale
boy oh boy that was mesmerizing absolutely
mesmerizing sort of attending a wedding
two days before this comes out I might be
in it I might be saying and I do that day
oh God I don't know so uh I don't know if
it's as important as Avatar I might have to
cancel my own wedding Greg's really
late I gotta get my review up woman yeah
I think this is cutting down a too long review oh
wow that looks just absolutely mesmerizing I can't
wait to see the different sides of the culture
than the new sea creatures to explore on top
of all of that too the action just has this like
strangely kinetic visceral energy with like this
strange kind of shutter speed to it that feels
like an anime again yeah you just keep wanting to
say that yeah it just looks so swelling and like
a just a fantastic visual Feast of an experience
needless to say three hours 14 minutes I think is
what the run time is for this yeah and that's also
how long every cast member can hold their breath
underwater I know it's impressive what'd you think
John I was dazzled by this and I love the fact
that with both of these trailers they are really
just leaning into tone food you know the general
Aura I mean like you get a lot of action in this
trailer this is a great international trailer
because it's like yeah they're not giving us
the exact plot but you could you you know what
the main conflict is gonna be you're gonna have
machines versus the natural world of the navi and
uh yeah it just looks so swelling and gripping and
everything underwater it is magical to watch this
because you know just how much Innovation and how
many effects brought all these shots to life
but and yet they feel like you just plopped a
camera there which I love that Duality because
it could easily be distracting and yet somehow
it's like I I could tell but also I'm just so
enamored with yeah how lovely and beautiful
this all looks yeah I thought this one really
leaned heavily into the action as well but at
the very beginning this is the most dialogue I
feel like we've gotten from the navi themselves
as well and I don't know the name of this other
culture that we're going to be dealing with I I
want to go on a little bit more blind to this than
than usual you know like I'm not really actively
researching to see what the details of the
plot are I do think there's going to be an
interesting kind of clash and exploration to to be
had there as well because they're very different
kinds of people as well you know which I think
helps separate it's a movie that the first one
especially dealt with like and that's going to
carry over the segregation themes those racism
themes that they're going to be dealing with it's
good to be getting like you know show that not all
of them are the same on this planet you know
yeah yeah maybe there will be conflicts from
within the different tribes and whatnot I mean it
seemed like they were fixing for a conflict with
Cliff Curtis there uh when he's like what are you
coming here looking for our help you know at the
same time it also feels like it's about Community
sure continuously like you get a lot of these
really like family themes it's a unique thing
about Avatar is that as epic of a scale as this
this film is it also is so much about family it's
one the whole family gets yeah I feel like this
will be the biggest movie of the year I mean I
think we're all opting for like one of the Marvel
movies but I feel like this one I'll do them yeah
because you could just feel you really can feel
feel the event that this is and you could feel how
10 years it took to make it yeah in a way that's
totally different than something like a Boyhood
or whatever you're like wow like having we we
were all a lot of us were there for the original
Avatar and for the innovations that that made and
then to see like the Leaps and Bounds after all
the many years of memes and people debating as
to whether or not it deserves to be the highest
grossing film ever like you you really feel the
double down in terms of just like craftsmanship
yeah that went into this and I feel like people
that's movie Magic and people respond to that
I mean and it looks like they're just embracing
the war aspect of it whereas the first one was
like territorial Invasion it was so much about
we gotta prevent a war from breaking out we got to
prevent a battle from breaking out and of course
that's not what happened you know it got really
nasty and ugly in the last hour of that film but
so much about it was preventing that and now it
seems like the goddamn us of a yeah well back
we're coming back looking for unobtaining yeah
they're stepping in there and they're like no
screw it we're just going out like we're hauling
ass in there we're gonna create all kinds of chaos
we don't care we got it the only way to do it is
by resorting to violence you know so it seems like
the necessity of them banding together but of
course you know also exploring um Jake and uh
natiri's what's her name that Terry yeah all
right Nokia well I was about to say the word
the colonizers but you're seeing Jake and
Terry's family too and exploring uh their
lives as children yeah yeah yeah yeah and what
it's saying having some of those those romances
seeing the other hot Navi girl from the water
emerging yeah yeah yeah it's beautiful it's
gonna be just all that shot of Phoebe Cates from
uh whatever that high school movie is but just
with Navi and their tiny tiny little garments
yeah they also got some like great POV shots
like it looks like James Cameron's really toying
with perspective a lot in this trailer too yeah
I mean this in the least insulting way possible
it looks like the coolest video game ever yeah no
it looks like a great video game yeah totally
um Jack in the VR and yeah looks amazing guys
what do you think about this trailer leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe click
that Bell leave a like hopefully we get a press
screening that way I don't have to piss your way
priorities babe and Hey listen for
the patron of the day shout out
Brandon Benzie Brandon you've been part of our
patreon page for four months now and I hope to see
you for another 12 more months that's right then
we can renegotiate 16 months but in the meantime
you are flowing through here so well like water
get what I just did there hey and I I love that
you love us to this degree and the best way to
show love is by money and so by you giving money
to US monthly on a consistent basis I feel loved
that is the key to anyone's heart unconditionally
Scholars so your supporter patreon has been
uh very very very much appreciative and in all
sincerity I hope you have a wonderful Thanksgiving
in Tucson Arizona yeah I hope you have an amazing
time out there hope it doesn't get too hot and uh
sweaty but then you know it also leads to a lot of
very beautiful people no matter what orientation
you are gay straight everyone's gonna be shirtless
in some capacity still have a good time regardless
get sweaty this Thanksgiving buddy way of sweat